guys it's like this it's sharknado with
no sharks that's what this is shark
leash sharknado
so shark leash shark net all right it's
called into the storm into this storm is
a movie about people who want to chase
tornadoes and so they chase tornadoes
it's a movie that doesn't really know
what the hell it wants to be is it found
footage is it not some shots or found
footage you can tell it's found footage
other shots are not found footage and
you don't know it's not found footage
and then it is found footage cuz it all
looks the same you don't know if it's
found footage or not unless someone
turns the camera he's like you know can
you turn that thing off right come with
me and you're like I guess this
particular shots found footage the next
one might not be but there will be
camera shots over someone's shoulder
that looks like found footage then it
shows the camera looking at him you're
like there's no one over his shoulder
with a camera so I guess it's not found
footage confusing [ __ ] man and there are
a few different storylines in this movie
you have the storm chasers that want to
chase these storms cool that should
concentrate on these people let's
concentrate on them nope then you have
this father who's trying to reconnect
with his kids and you have this romance
with this other kid and this other high
school student chick and these
hillbillies holy [ __ ] these guys these
comedic really feel but alright check
this I know what this is now come on
Transformers Revenge of the Fallen they
reveal the Transformers can transform
into human beings I don't know how or
why but they can then you never saw
mudflap and skids again in any of the
Transformers movies you like where'd
they go hey now I know they're in into
the storm there's all these different
plot lines all these different people
you're like get off the screen let's
watch the storm chasers chase the
tornadoes and let's watch tornadoes tear
the [ __ ] out of things and I'm not gonna
[ __ ] all over this movie because when
the tornadoes were actually tearing
through town I actually looked pretty
cool and I liked it fact is the first
half of this movie's boring is [ __ ] it's
all the setup with stupid characters you
don't care but you're like you exist
tell me you exist just for a tornado to
suck you up into the air and drop you
there were a couple times someone gets
sucked into the tornado and I'm like who
are you again only thing that was
missing was a red Star Trek shirt man
you see some of these people you're like
well I don't buy it's like this movie
would have killed it in the 90s this
movie came out about 17 years too late
it missed the boat by that much they
knew this twister just got released in
the box office it killed it a couple
years later you have this movie
everyone's like oh well [ __ ] twister was
cool so let's watch the other twisters
not a great movie but it was fun from
what I remember then this movie comes
out a couple years after twister and
just destroys it that would
have been optimal for this it's like
someone wrote it and forgot about it and
then now is almost like oh hey this
script into the storm I think my friend
wrote that uh yeah let's make that those
tornado movie still make money right
there's still much money no grandpa they
don't cuz you're out of touch you don't
know that they don't in the end this
movie is full of people you don't care
about worse this movie tries to make you
care about the people you don't care
about however when you see tornadoes
wrecking through towns and tearing [ __ ]
up that is actually entertaining so I'm
not going to give this movie the dog
[ __ ] that it probably is because if I
was entertained in a movie it's not dog
[ __ ] but I will say you're not gonna
remember this movie in t minus 20
minutes yep this movie had tornadoes
wrecking towns and I already forgot
coolest part of this movie is I met
three fans at the movie theater they
watched guardians of the galaxy I
watched this I realized my fans are
smarter than me I take the hit so you
don't have to go into the store maybe
you haven't seen it never mind even
gonna waste my time asking that [ __ ]
summers winding down so what was your
favorite movie of the summer movie
season that's a pretty good one whatever
it is comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]